[Music]
I'm excited that everyone finally able
to meet yes everyone's in the room all
right cool hell yeah we did a few things
like straight up right off the bed but I
think you know Gary and a neat should
talk about always growing up immigrant
community similar to youth there's you
know one bedroom a lot of people share
that room similar like there's a lot of
similar thing with desks right
oh yeah then you guys can maybe like
build off of and then also like the
music so the kite kite project he's
really like telling his story like
talking about Queens New York but also
like you know yes like it's just there
on the intro and takes you through the
borough and really telling his story and
it's such an important time for like the
immigrant story in general just with
what's going on with America so it's
like he's really like shaped enough to
has this area is a good following but
it's like really looking like it might
go crazy and then the other thing that I
think is really trusting is he did an
interview with beats one reasonably and
was one of the things he said was you
know for a while he was looking at
himself like they're looking at the goal
like if it was a kite or whatever like
Madison Square Gardens the goal but then
you started to look at it more as like
whose hopes nearing that type so it's
almost like reverse engineering and now
he's focusing more on like the people
who are brain is there and getting up
there and like his face in his
communities so I thought it was pretty
pretty cool and along the lines of a lot
of the stuff you're talking about
so I'm excite you guys they're beating
right now thanks boy what's awesome meet
you guys
you know pleasure yeah for sure so you
know talking about reverse engineering
like knowing that you have a little
context you know I think what's most
always interesting to me and I'm I know
that you guys have a sense that Boyd and
I are meeting with a lot of artists and
it's really a very simple model
I just basically trust Boyd implicitly
and then it becomes a game of like how
do I bring disproportionate value and
then the chips fall
you know karma is practical right that's
really kind of how I think about it and
so
you know would love to know in the short
term or long term if there's anything I
can help with and then answer anything
that might be on your mind and that's
kind of like it's really quite simple
app for me right like I just feel like
obviously music and specifically hip-hop
music is so culturally important to me
and that's why I associated with it
because whether it's India Russia or in
the african-american communities it's
all the same story of the rising up
right and so would love to know if
there's anything that pops you know
especially if you have that much context
I mean like anything I can help with or
any I'd love to know a little bit more
about the story or how it's going in or
the State of the Union of where we're at
right now absolutely so the project
kites and like I was saying it's a
psycho perspective and an aerial
perspective of what's important to me
now and how many projects have you
dropped to - yeah and the first one yeah
this is my first full life the first one
was called I don't know yet and I was
going to like a lot of it when she
should yep because we didn't know yet I
get it
it's a good name for a first project so
kind one was that that was and how many
it was a mixtape yeah how many songs oh
oh I have a lot of travel this week so
I'm going to listen to everything this
week oh okay go ahead sorry okay I will
okay but you know what's funny like I
get it and like I go through it like I
think about my books or my talks there's
still so much good stuff in the first
you know first of all the first thing
with me with hip-hop is I don't actually
really think I understand music very
well the reason I think I resonate so
much with hip-hop is I only care about
the words I'm almost in like poem and
like reading mentality like to me the
artists I'm most associated with there's
nothing to do with Beats or the hook
nothing it's a hundred percent the words
the analogies like or just like clever
cultural relevance does that make me
laugh you know I still think I love 21
savage because he mentioned Randy
- man savage I'm not even sure there was
anything else you know I'm listening to
a lot I mean so what's funny about the
way I listen so listen to a lot of older
nods right now weirdly enough yeah it's
super interesting Boyd's feeding me a
lot of good stuff like a lot of female
vocalists or super interesting to me and
then like you know that cardi like I
like seeing like wow I love analyzing
why right like to me I'm a really good
at reverse engineering so like watching
whether it's you know what Coach K's
trying to do with his artists and like
will it work like what happens when you
fought like I grew up when P Diddy was
like okay now it's Mase right now it's
this and like trying to figure out like
even when you have so I have all the
marketing leverage when I lose or win in
20 years from now there's a reason why
even when you have all the leverage
certain artists don't win right you can
put them on they can like they can show
up on every right track
you can put 20 million dollars behind
them they could be in rap caviar why
don't they win so a lot of what I do
with music is more of like trying to
figure out why things organically win
when can you make something win when it
wouldn't have won without you and why
you lose when the Machine tried to put
everything behind you well you should
talk about
I don't know yet right yeah yeah yes
definitely before like I heard before we
do that
who are you hurry who's everybody in the
crew you're the artist that I understand
writing agent and how do you guys
connect oh so that that's where it kind
of like we had sparring was me and Tommy
the manager I said I tweeted that a week
after I saw him live because that's when
he won me over
sure like it's like this thing that was
like mixing hey what do you do I'm
publicist so I do look for music for I'm
using all this yeah understood music
policies so you're living your life
you've heard a little bit you see him
live there like now I now I believe ya
and hit him up okay we do that young man
we connected yep took a couple of
meetings together understood awesome
okay yeah so I come in and unique and we
I heard his song two years ago before
the first project I don't know yet and
just on soundcloud or Spotify just on
soundcloud and immediately you know I
connected yes exactly and you had
aspirations to manage at this point yes
did you manage anybody at this point no
I was but it was in the back of your
mind because he was bridging but before
you heard that song yeah you're sitting
in your room in your life you thought
about managing artists yeah yeah yeah I
was involved I've known Mike do college
radio I didn't radio at NYU and then I
was a writer for different publications
and stuff like that around hip hop yes
yeah it's like complex understood work
saw something that understood yeah yeah
so you co-manage yeah yeah yeah like
dharmic kinda life for a while you would
sound like the UH whiz kid in New York
lovely a little bit it's like Amanda
actually I've been wanting you to meet
Amanda for a while and I think I don't
know if she's doing this but she was
this bald and some others thankfully
what Baynard would do like with brands
and marketing and stuff like that - so
understood our story is kind of fun so I
used to rap
we met actually connected them to and I
was like Yanni to speak I run it digital
agency now but I work with an econ a
whole bunch of stuff I love it yes so
we've all come what's name your company
green and creative la semaine Cabrillo
that follow things with religious that
you do but also you know with this guy
you know getting him to be social on
social them and really leveraging I get
it they the team is strong so awesome
give it I guess how are you nice to meet
you man such a pleasure
here take this you sure well positive
nope that's not how we do it
okay understood okay let's go back to it
now yeah so cuz it's obviously it's like
that who I think I am Doug how old are
you so yeah you look great
you know before I used to think like all
of us the biggest thing on long I said
no Madison Square and all this stuff
right and like it was all completely
focused on okay of course not what's
more important to me are the people
staring it and the people like are
waiting to be there when I fall it's in
the movie you know put me back of course
it's kind of like a soundcheck
two queens from like Queens positives
you make a have right um everything in
between
um
and that's kind of like what I just
recently released when did it come out
yeah have we met before I don't believe
so
okay oh yeah actually just the way your
face turned I was like we did okay don't
worry I've been a cop like two months
later I'm a fair set by the show which
was Wow where was that okay first of all
I've never had a show like I've never I
get it so that helped and how many peeps
awesome for yeah crazy right yeah it's
really cool three bro
there is the none of the top thing yeah
felt great yeah it was like I've never
seen people recite my music like that
right I don't know [ __ ] it on one stage
but that day I thought that because you
were just blown away by it with your
mind started veering into that I get it
let's know all the songs I get it I
understand
and then right after I went on my first
national tour with Jude Emma he was kind
enough to put me in there though yeah it
was a really dope experience and I've
been back for a couple weeks and I'm
like budget
now some marriage I got some for you I
project with three businesses and queens
that I think make the flavors and loud
music and basically like this North
African halal food cart it was about so
Middle Eastern which is kind of like
that flavor also with this West Indian
restaurant culture in City roti which is
kind of like the West Indian and South
Asian flavor that I have in my music and
then just a Chinese father's just love
it and it's like all three of those I
got the minions in the front and they're
[ __ ] in the back like they're there I
got wet to want like you know when you
go to those hole in the walls and I was
like yeah I don't like works that much
because I don't like like I don't know
where like train stuff and I'm aware
yourself with like stuff on it it's like
what what I wear because if I'm gonna
make my dough a hundred percent yeah so
I went I was like just eating that trans
City and I was like yo that's sure to
spire like their address the phone
number your phone number no you know
what that's my marriage that's I mean
that's cool I like it
part of them and but just made it more
like you know kind of like my style and
we kind of played on made in Bangladesh
because all the [ __ ] would go
and take advantage of my people and of
course do it all this [ __ ] like I
actually custom tailored these every
single piece in Bangladesh with you know
the lines with my boy fee
Manufacturing and there's like a lot of
layers to like everything as I
essentially put out because you know
bhavish hasn't really been represented
in this environment Oh yep at all that's
really cool so what's your story Boyd's
been dying for us to connect yes yeah
you know I met boy my brother was
working for society that clothing brand
that was really well brothers through
jokes I mean and boy was helping them
with stuff and we literally I was with
the owner
this dude Brenda and my brother driving
around Queens picking up merch
first-first like we needed like sample
stuff and he had some of it isn't like a
walk they like stop by his house to walk
into the car and we like connected and
never spoke for like two years then we
ran into each other something like oh
and since then we've been like just
trying to make all the things thanks
where we can for each other it's really
right or my brother works in real estate
is that how you saw Boyd so yeah it's
yeah I had it on beautiful yeah it's
been pretty epic yeah you got jump in
the car yeah it's been working out well
what can what can I answer if anything
anybody have any questions yeah
like obviously
you're really good at like you know
looking at things from short-term and
also looking at things from long time
and I guess like
long term super easy my man it just
comes down to one very very simple thing
legacy versus currency it's that basic
it you're just making decisions on an
everyday basis about two things the kite
up and down to Boyd's part the only
reason I think I'm a little bit
different than people are understanding
it is because I have an unbelievably
weird relationship with money and stuff
which is I don't like them
I don't notice si every decision I make
is predicated on my legacy all of them
I've never made a decision for money in
my entire life even when I didn't have
it even like I need it enough to have
rent and stuff but it's never been the
driver because I think it comes down to
something that I've been trying to
unpack myself I think the reason that's
true is because I think I'm gonna end up
being all time
I just don't think I need it and I think
every time I take it it just slows it
down so here's what I mean by that if
you're thinking SuperDuper long time and
long term well then you have to when you
look at who you surround yourself with
what shows you're gonna do what works
you put out what's your next song's
title what project you're doing who
you're [ __ ] with what meetings you're
taking who you marry how you roll you
look at of it in one perspective which
is when I'm 87 how the [ __ ] am I gonna
feel about this and if you're that in
tune with yourself and I don't know if
everybody is or isn't I can't speak to
that but I can give you the answer to
why I've gotten here and how I've gotten
about doing it which is it's all
long-term Boyd's long-term for me might
poured a lot of dollars and energy and
efforts into different [ __ ] [ __ ]
Romanian things that way tonight but
wait
Boyd and I have come up with it's not
like he's my child and I'm Boyd and I
but like because I always knew at a
macro it was right and so I just always
think long term yeah because I don't
need anything short term and that's it
so like you need to start making
decisions on you know how you think
about those two things
it's just legacy and currency it's just
money and how you feel and everybody
gives up how they feel for short term
money and then they try to reconstruct
it later
problem is everything's on the record
yeah we know jay-z did a Budweiser
commercial
so that's it man like and I think the
key for me is I've never wavered from
when nobody knew who I was a lot more
people now who know who I am just the
same [ __ ] every day forever and I know
forever I love when people like oh
especially my closest friends and
everybody now like man it's getting so
weird like hope you don't change like
like you haven't figured out what I'm
doing here so I think that's super
simple it's just you got to figure out
that you just need to know yourself now
by the way some people want a car some
people want to put their mom in a
penthouse like you're you but understand
this every time you pick the money
you're taking a couple of pebbles out of
the legacy place right the end get it
parents buy wrecked by understanding the
score just understand the score like
just knowing that truth I've taken it I
I bought an apartment on the Upper East
Side which made me less liquid which
didn't allow me to put as much money
into Facebook and uber and Twitter my
lost hundreds of millions of dollars
because I needed a million dollars for
an apartment that was a mistake right
like right now I really want to help my
family business so I'm pushing white on
my social media and I'm throwing right
hooks that's taking away cuz for the
last 18 months I've had the luxury of
just giving at scale just knowing the
score and I feel great about helping out
my dad's business at the expense of me
losing people's attention because they
don't want to hear about why I'm cool
with that but you're gonna for that
I I don't think so I think like I can't
afford it I'm [ __ ] pissed about giving
up leverage the understand it's binary I
I could afford it if you decide that I
have dollars but like but that's not
what I'm training for shit's not even
benefiting me so it's double [ __ ]
annoying you know it'd be one thing if
it was like you know what I mean so
you're either giving or you're taking
there's no one between and I just try to
give as much as possible that's why you
know a lot of I know a lot of people in
this community I know people gonna watch
this right now and everybody's yelling
at me of like you're giving the same
advice of putting out music too much
music I'm like you don't get it
like putting out a song is giving it's
[ __ ] free this isn't how I grew up
and you're putting out a [ __ ] tape
double-sided two songs and you want four
dollars out of the back of your [ __ ]
like out of the back of your trunk this
is you uploading [ __ ] to a streaming
service that everybody's getting for
[ __ ] free I mean macro $9 whatever
but like free yeah and you're giving me
three minutes of escapism and you may
say something that inspires me to do
something and it may benefit you because
you might be that one song away just
like logic finally have his song puts
him in a totally different place so
giving that's what I do I put out a song
for free every day it's called [ __ ]
day levy like I don't have the same
skills you have I have my own version
and it costs nothing like so when people
like Oh Gary you don't know the music
business I'm like I know the attention
business which trumps everything and I'm
doing my I'm eating my own dog food I'm
getting high on my supply I'm doing what
I'm telling people to do I'm putting out
[ __ ] every day music every day I believe
in it the most I will be proven to be
right in 15 years when everyone's like
[ __ ] it was music every day the problem
is are you good enough to put out music
every day
like plenty people can be vlogging
everyday nobody gives a [ __ ] because
they were worth three [ __ ] days but
if you think you're worth [ __ ] 365
days a year of songs I would highly
recommend that you and your crew here
think long and hard of how to do that in
a strategic way now you may say I have
81 songs a year or six that's on you but
I would tell you as an artist the number
one advice I have for you and every
single artist watching is figure out how
many songs a year you have in you
because once you figure that out then
you put your strategy around that and
then you [ __ ] win because if you're
like look I got eight songs a year and
me eight [ __ ] songs and everybody's
gonna figure out how many bangers versus
volume but like everybody's got I
understand what everyone's debating if
it's eight well then then go sign a
[ __ ] record deal and make the most
money you can on eight but if you've got
96 in you you better [ __ ] just build
attention at scale and build the
leverage
our supervisor you know what I mean
because that's what I'm doing the reason
not everybody can do what I'm doing in
business everybody wants to is they
don't have as much content in them as I
do yeah right got it
that's the 2.0 of what I've been trying
to say I'm glad I finally said it which
is me good for you because a lot more
people gonna watch this now that that
would be the number one strategy first
you know people overthink projects
signing not signing number one binary if
you're an artist how many great songs
good songs songs can I put out a year
and do I have the energy for it and how
do I do it and can I afford it and and
am I in it and like how do I do it but
that would be the biggest piece of
advice and then the first part of this
meeting man legacy currency when you ask
you're giving up leverage when you're
giving you're gaining leverage and
balancing that with your audience as
everything so I'm loved because I'm
[ __ ] giving more than I'm taking a
hundred persistence because we're used
to not having anything my kids have no
shot they're used to having stuff you
know they're used to having stuff so
like the thought of not like to me
people don't get it I can go back to
zero I'm like Rocky in that sixth movie
like I'm good I'll go right back to
[ __ ] rego park live in a studio
apartment go to wall bounce and be good
dreaming up how I'm gonna come back and
[ __ ] rise like a phoenix right be
like and read every [ __ ] comment of
like I knew Gary Vee was a fraud I never
he sucked
I knew he'd fall one day and just
[ __ ] eat that [ __ ] to motivate myself
to get back up and come back and be like
I [ __ ] told you so like to me it's
equally as interesting to go back to
zero as it is to go to [ __ ] hero and
that means you're on the you're
unbeatable that's why immigrants win cuz
once you taste it you don't want to go
back cuz you're like [ __ ] that suck this
is better but you're not completely
petrified of it cuz you've been there
done that
hundred percent I've done it once I can
do it again which then allows you to
take the risks which then allows you to
give because when you suck you're taking
yeah yeah and one want them to quickly
add some context around the area was
just talking about like if you have a
song a year you and you make your plan
around it like another things is Gary
please well one thing Gary's gonna watch
a bunch of Gary's stuff smell like when
Gary talking about the detention and
stuff he just told a bogey for example
like you know it's in a song it's not
taking off you wanted to get hotter like
watch you go to the firaon store watch
you tell your fans that meet you
somewhere or in your case like go to
like somewhere in Queens or something
like creative content is it like if you
do because one thing for you to know
Gary is a I was talking to it because
unlike a lot of these guys in Atlanta
they're just like clips video view is
talented he kind of just goes this video
boy two weeks at a time it's like crunch
time we're not from cyber winds inspired
or like create a project go in it giving
that knowledge it's almost like because
create a lot of video content and a
whole lot of other stuff like you know
as long as you're keeping people's
attention it could still work you know
like whatever number was bomb number one
doubt with points other thing you do
know it's seeing a boogie do that pop up
the other day made me smile cheek to
cheek
yeah that was insane that really worked
for him no [ __ ] because when you get
when you because I'm right about this
stuff if you give you get you know I bet
I definitely when I saw that I actually
I when we went to LA I feel like really
it was like my first times I stayed for
like oh yeah yeah six days I didn't know
I knew how fast but the show's already
sold out before I got on the tour like
and so I see this pop-up for my merch we
just picked the place and I think Joe
tires like I couldn't stop moving I get
it man it's the best feeling ever
come on that doing that I feel like I'm
not so heard you said before learn
that's the most important part to me is
100% talking to them personally and
giving them something person they need
to have they talked about that yep every
batch is frags more everybody wants with
everybody wants a million followers I'll
take a thousand if every one of them
does what I want them to do and gets
what they want out of it yeah it's a
hundred percent and engagement isn't
likes or shares agents going to shows or
wearing a menu on your shirt or taking
their time to tell their friends like
you need to listen to this person stuff
yeah I think you need to give now that
boy just put that context of studio I'm
telling you right now brother please
think about how many songs you have in
you and you may not come in like you
maybe never thought of it like you need
to go inside yourself and figure that
out once you have that figured out I'm
telling you that's the new blueprint
once you understand that then you could
because there's a lot of everybody's
doing the same [ __ ] everybody put out
[ __ ] albums then everybody put out 45
smack that everybody put out albums now
everybody's putting out music on the
internet mixtapes projects right I'm
like look if you have 150 songs than you
not everyone can be in your next project
then take 13 of them and give them to
the biggest bloggers on YouTube be like
yo I made this for you
Paul Brothers here like if you that's
your mo and and overthinking the
distribution to fit the box that
everybody's doing is the way not to do
it like somebody here needs to email
every video game company and be like we
have a great artist we have [ __ ] real
[ __ ] beats fire like we'll give them
to you just put them in the pre-roll of
the game or anywhere else people's
attention is hit up a [ __ ] college
that has a big radio station and be like
Duke University we're giving this to you
like opening lines like yo Duke what up
go like you yeah cuz you have that song
in you and what you're gonna sit and
scrutinize it and cut it from the
project at the end so what it's gonna
sit and [ __ ] somebody's harddrive
right the [ __ ] yeah
execution yeah take every [ __ ] back to
legacy versus currency
I built Wine Library in a big business
because when I built it from a3 I'm
looking at the plaque with me my dad
because when it went from three to 45
and went to three to 45 because much
like every other liquor store New Jersey
owned by Indian families who are all my
dude my relationship with the Indian
community is crazy like Edison New
Jersey literally in 1986 is where
everybody came is Lin and Edison my dad
owns the only building in Islan not
owned by an Indian the only one oh dude
it's crazy things yes he must be mad
what [ __ ] dude it it's it's India when
you get in there real miles of bingeing
businesses and I'm crazy this is crazy
it's you so you know I'm the immigrant
in Edison New Jersey from 82 to 86 and
Edison because I'm the Russian kid and
then one summer goes by and we go into
fifth grade 82 three four five in 1986
four new kids in my class have the last
name Patel seven of them are from India
and I'm pumped because I'm like okay
good new immigrants right what I didn't
know was they were really gonna be my
homies cuz these kids were like me they
were here to [ __ ] sell [ __ ] flip
baseball cards make money like grind so
it went from first I like because I
wasn't gonna be the odd man out then I
was like wait a minute these are my
homies so then that's my first chapter
then I go into the liquor business in
1998 from 1992 to 19 to 2015 all of New
Jersey's liquor stores 80% of them were
bought by Indian American immigrants the
whole industry don't like because
they're hustlers they made they made
thing cool that's cool now I'm there
then I go into tech and start meeting
all these developers and they're all
Alex oh yeah I've always had a I've
always had a pretty amazing relationship
with the community because it's because
I'm because I'm built like that
community and I'm innocent I think a lot
about the hip-hop african-american
community sir it's just the same [ __ ]
which is when you don't have anything
and you're willing to work the way you
leverage it is first of all that you
don't have to do anything because the
truth always wins you're part of it it's
naturally going to come to you you want
to speed it up there's a very easy way
it's called Facebook my biggest I think
that's my biggest even while I was going
even though like I was down I'm an
immigrant but even more than that like I
grew up in lower-income apartments so I
wasn't around for nollies right so I was
I was around Americans and Hispanics and
that's how you ended up here right
because I understand the perspective of
what they're coming from but I also
still know my heritage and what I'm
doing it's just that balance or both of
it it's such a home run
I wish I never left Queens I mean it you
know it's crazy I got real lucky we
moved to basically a very lower
middle-class white neighborhood for my
high school like it's crazy like I'd
never been around well for my whole life
all right it's the best thing that ever
happened to me yeah people asking why
you so closely if dumbasses cuz I never
had you okay a hundred percent me and
I'm the same way I get it
need to tell yours true stories man
they're universal yeah it's not Indian
or Russian or black or it's universal
these stories are universal it's just
the same stories with a different coat
of paint there's there's only two
stories the haves and have-nots
that's it
you gotta figure out how much music
Avenue man that's the best piece of nice
they can give you okay that will help
you because because if you have and I
don't know maybe you know like again I
am I'm definitely a brick I don't I'm
definitely not this easy about song
about muscle you know what that's great
even though my vibes go towards the 365
like Mazel like if it's [ __ ] sixteen
you could be so smart that yeah that
gets into your team getting together
like honestly even like just this team I
think that's helpful I don't know how
much pressure you guys have put on this
conversation but if I know that you're
saying it's twelve you guys need to
think a real step back and be like okay
we need to strategize around projects in
a different if you can launch four
projects a year or once a week songs
versus having one project a year you
have a totally different [ __ ] 365
days yeah that's what we just we just
actually sobbing I'm sorry service
company sovereign I'm aware also because
we you know I know that I don't mean
like music like that I'd still want to
like push kites and like the project
really popular at them and figure out
like more video content and 100 percent
you know like dude you get do you right
yeah how often right now yeah like how
do you do how do you do write your music
yeah good how do you write you write so
it's there and then you just go improv
I'm not going to the studio spin it from
the dome well I'll write in the studio
as well just in my head I I still think
nobody's figured out I think somebody
needs to be documenting the entire
writing process alright
if I could see how the 15 songs that I
love the most
origin stories why do you think comic
books win comic books win I got
something like they win cuz we know
spider-man got bit by [ __ ] spider
like one of those [ __ ]
you know like origin stories I think are
missing thing like if I was like oh my
God my favorite hook that you ever came
up with was because you tripped like
going to Burger King and you're like
damn skinny skinned knees like like I
don't know because I we have these great
content ideas but then I feel that
because this media industry is so
consumed by content that they want to
make their own I feel like sometimes
worried to look debilitated because you
have to wait till someone says like oh
people will do that rather than just
putting it out yeah I don't look I get
the complex that Casal look like I get
it but I didn't wait for Wall Street
Journal or fortune or Forbes to put me
on you have something called YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram and snapchat
you just need right now with the fact
that you have fans somebody will work
for free to be Tyler follow you around
with a camera he's 17 years old he loves
your music the most in the world
he's got nothing else going on and he's
gonna follow you around for free and
that's that can't wait to listen man
thank you
I love it I'm gonna rock him oh you know
what though because I really want to
rock them can somebody send me mediums
because I won't wear these largest Oh
tight yeah just kind of break you know
what and I will 100% rocco better
movies perfect Aldo got it perfect I
love it I need to run cuz I got my dad's
charity wine event but I'd love to take
some photos
yeah damn put you on a little bit what's
going on on your Instagram
how's it going it's what is your
Instagram in Flour Ali Khan and I gave
and hiked a cage and it's one word yep
is law review I see it love it followed
you need to push way more often the
thing every day the story every day okay
every day the biggest thing I'm gonna
tell you that kind of feel already if
you're precious
you'll lose damn okay dude I told you
the first time we ever met about music
yeah right when we get outside you know
what I mean I get it yeah but I'm
telling you with all my heart I want you
to win
if you're precious you lose okay the
amount of real talents that are losing
out of preciousness and then it's over
[Music]